[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so the Senate has rejected a
bill to ban most abortions after 20
weeks of pregnancy or into a pregnancy
and it's basically a symbolic vote which
is hoping to force vulnerable Democrats
to take a stand which might hurt them if
they are running for re-election in red
states or states that are often sort of
purple states but were won by Donald
Trump in the 2016 election and it was a
fifty one to forty six vote the measure
fell short of the 60-vote threshold
that's required for the Senate to break
a democratic filibuster and it's not
surprising it basically was along party
lines similar vote took place in the
Senate in 2015 and at that time there
were three Democrats Bob Casey a Joe
Donnelly and Joe Manchin who voted in
favor of it and all three are up for
re-election this year in states that
Donald Trump carried and they're all
also they also voted in favor again on
Monday susan collins and lisa murkowski
not surprisingly voted with most of the
democrats against this bill what do you
think about this because it's similar to
like the net neutrality vote which also
is a vote that has some element of
putting people on record and then maybe
being used to campaign for or against in
the midterm election what are you with
your sense of this vote it's such a
personal issue and it's entirely for
political posturing whereas the net
neutrality bill actually does have some
chance I mean like they have 50 votes in
the Senate you only need one more and
then if it does pass then you're halfway
there well divide a devil's out of a
symbolic a play devil's advocate the
people who believe that life begins at
conception would say this is not a
personal issue of just women deciding
what to do with their bodies they would
say this is the paramount issue it is an
issue of human rights and it is an issue
of preventing the murders of unborn
children
so I agree with you and I happen to
share your view but if you believe that
life begins at conception it's the issue
of killing babies or unborn babies or
whatever you want to call them is not a
personal issue it's an issue of
defending children or whatever but if
you think that life begins at conception
then you want an all-out abortion ban
not 20 weeks and I understand that's
maybe what they could reasonably shoot
for sure a lot of them do believe when
you talk to them they say well we want a
total abortion ban but in order to do
that we need to start moving back some
how low so let's start with the 20-week
threshold and then once that's law then
we can continue to push I mean this is
their argument it's certainly a viable
that they yeah we can have but they know
that they don't have the votes it's
entirely to get these Democratic
senators on record and you know it seems
like it's it's below the belt in a
certain way I guess it really isn't oh
no I mean I don't think it's gonna work
ultimately it's not going to legal
abortion has a 57 percent favorability
higher than ever in the country and
that's higher than ever I don't know
exactly how those numbers stack up in
those purple states that some of these
Democratic senators are vulnerable yeah
but we'll see I guess to finalize the
devil's advocate yep you said part of
the reason why you're against this is
that it doesn't have any chance you can
make the same case about the net
neutrality thing which is that even if
it were to pass the Senate it's not
going to pass the House and even if it
were to pass the house
Trump's vetoing it so that maybe you
could make that argument still well I
mean we've talked to a few people we've
talked to Craig Aaron about this talk to
inter Torres yep and I think both said
that you know once it does pass the
Senate then we're gonna have a worthy
conversation
and maybe because I good momentum that
that will be momentum yeah we'll reach
out to their Congress people and we
don't even know what Trump's position is
on net neutrality it's not like you know
House Republicans trying to overturn the
Affordable Care Act something like 60
times I know we're sure that the
president isn't going to sign off on it
gee a piece of legislation Trump
appointed to G PI and then the FCC
immediately repealed it so even if Trump
doesn't really know what his position is
and he doesn't even know what net
neutrality is which I believe he doesn't
he's got a veto but Trump does have
disagreements with
GPI and we're gonna see that later in
the week we're gonna do story about the
nationalized 5g yeah oh right and they
have a disagreement there so I mean it's
not like because he appointed him that
he signs off on every single thing that
the GDI supports certainly not certainly
not we'll see what happens with it
there's a California politician who in
order to try to protect the environment
proposed the bill which would make it a
crime for restaurants where you eat in
the restaurant to offer plastic straws
without first being asked and this is
Democratic Assemblyman ian Calderon he's
been targeted by people calling his
proposal absurd and a total overreach so
he's not suggesting that plastic straws
be banned he is suggesting that plastic
straws in restaurants not be offered by
default but only if the person who is
dining asks for one now couple thoughts
on this number one I don't really drink
out of a straw so when I'm at a
restaurant and they bring me my glass of
water and a straw if the straw is
wrapped I just don't touch it if the
straw is unwrapped and already in the
water I take it out and I put it on the
side because I just don't really drink
out of straws so they're not my thing
yeah there's another layer to this
altogether which is that there are
restaurants and I went to one here in
the Boston area over the weekend for
brunch that has switched from plastic
straws to recyclable paper straws it's
basically like a piece of paper that's
tightly wound into a straw shape and it
was interesting and I didn't use one
again because I don't drink out of
straws but other people at my table did
but after about 15 minutes it starts to
become soggy and fall apart and they
ended up needing three total paper
straws during the meal know which it's
they're still all recyclable but is it
kind of out undoing some of the benefit
of not having a plastic I don't think
I'd like the texture you know I don't
like I don't think I would like how it
feels to put like a paper straw yeah I
mouth
now what about reusable straws something
made out of metal that you could wash
maybe well listen in Argentina it's very
common that people there is this it's
not tea but it's a tea like thing called
Mata I'm calling it tea like even though
it is
something else and it's an herbal thing
and you drink it out of a gourd
typically with a metal straw and
typically people also share the same
metal straw so you pass it around it's
very thing very unhygenic but it's a
communal thing yeah exactly and people
bring their own metal straws with them I
mean in other words people have a kit I
guess is what I mean with their gourd
and their metal straw and I don't know
why we're even talking about that
because it doesn't directly relate but
it's a metal straw thing and then even
even more interestingly in OGG why it's
common for people to walk on the street
with their Gordon that are metal straw
and then a thermos of hot water because
the way it works is that you steep it
many many times so like you fill it with
water and you drink the water out of the
gourd but then you add more water and
you can kind of like drink out of it
throughout the day and a new Duguay it's
very common to see people walking the
streets with their little thermos and
their wooden gourd and their eye gourds
are wood right or at least some of them
are yeah and they're metal straw and and
okay it has nothing to do with plastic
straws in California restaurants but
just a little little flavor from South
America for you I hope you don't want me
to respond to that please respond to the
use of metal straws in Argentina yeah
okay so yeah back sister the penalty for
these restaurants yep if you know they
just give out straws and don't ask the
people ahead of time right is hilarious
it's a one thousand dollar fine and/or
six months in prison it's absurd it's
absurd and I get it he's trying to do
something for the environment is mr.
caldron but this doesn't seem like the
right way to go about it and I
understand why why he's being criticized
it's just a six months in jail for
giving people straws without straw being
asked forming come on this bill sounded
ridiculous to begin with but six months
in jail that's the final straw that's it
that's the final straw absolutely good
one
Massachusetts Congressman Joe Kennedy
the third is going to be giving
tonight's Democratic response to Trump
State of the Union address I kind of
like this he's super young he's 37 he is
also a Kennedy so he's part of that
dynasty but I find him to be
yeah and articulate in a way that is
appealing to me and I think that this is
an interesting one and he is sort of
seen as a rising star in the Democratic
Party although I'm hesitant of more
political dynasties yeah well he's
intelligent he's measured he's
compassionate is everything is not top
Democratic leaders announced this a few
days ago and they had heaps of praise or
mountains of praise to heap upon Joe
Kennedy and he's the nephew great nephew
of former Senator Ted Kennedy and John F
Kennedy and he is also what other family
he is the father second he's the
grandson of the late Robert Kennedy
Bobby US Attorney General in New York
senator yeah yeah I like this choice
well I don't I think that the responses
to the State of the Union can be done
away with yeah they're always incredibly
awkward it's just like a one-shot of the
person speaking directly to the camera
there's no audience
it's very scripted the people are often
very awkward in their delivery I'm
trying to remember the awkward ones that
a place during Obama so let me let me
see if I can remember though and you
tell me which one's I'm missing or which
ones didn't actually take place Rand
Paul and no no no Marco Rubio and the
water incident Watergate that was yes
Watergate Watergate to was Marco Rubio
Bobby Jindal
the governor from Louisiana coming out
with what I call pedophile eyes even
though maybe that's considered
inappropriate but I think we all know
exactly what I'm talking about and and
seeming completely manic and looking at
the camera
did Sarah Palin do one once I don't
think though okay
there was a Michele Bachmann Oh directly
off of the camera I think I had the
teleprompter instead of under the camera
like next to the camera so it was like
this weird eye contact thing going on
any others that are particularly Joni
Ernst the owners from Iowa who talked
about when she was younger they didn't
have a lot of money yep so in order to
protect their shoes her parents would
put red bags around them yep and tie
them onto her feet and she wasn't
embarrassed
because she would get on the school bus
and every other kid on the bus also had
bread bags tied onto their feet and they
also would castrate pigs or something I
think that was her campaign ad yeah
remember when she was supposedly going
to be like the rising star of the
Republican Party oh yeah basically not
been heard from since the Koch brothers
back there yeah I don't know where she
goes forward from here you know
hopefully back to I whatever on the farm
to do whatever it was she was doing pigs
okay well anyway I'll probably check out
Joe Kennedy's response even though I
agree with you it's kind of a pointless
tradition right and it's done like ahead
of time all this stuff I mean you've
always pre-recorded oh no it's not
pre-recorded but regardless of what the
president says in the speech all right
they don't have the same script to read
although presumably they're writing the
response speech based on the early
release of the State of the Union speech
on to them as well right which is
usually embargoed yeah I and man the
question is like would this be allow him
to launch a political career further
than Jim's just being a congressman like
put him in the national eye yeah and the
answer is probably no yeah the only
person that really has done well after
giving a response to the State of the
Union is Paul Ryan yeah it was now of
course Speaker the house wait about it
he was already sort of prominent when he
gave yeah I don't know if it was before
or after he ran alongside Mitt Romney
defo all right so we'll be watching
tonight we'll have analysis tomorrow
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]